in november 2015
197 countries came together in paris and
agreed to pursue efforts to limit the
temperature increase on our planet
to 1.5 degrees celsius the climate
action tracker monitors the climate
commitments and actions of 36 countries
totaling roughly 80 percent of today's
global greenhouse gas emissions
here's the bad news those emissions are
still rising and have already warmed the
globe by 1.1 degrees
celsius the tracker makes two problems
clear
first countries have not set emissions
targets ambitious enough to reach the
goals of the paris agreement
even if every country hit their targets
the temperature would still increase by
more than 2 degrees celsius
over the next 70 years and continue to
rise
into the 22nd century and beyond second
governments are simply not delivering
even on their unambitious targets
everything these 36 countries have done
so far and everything they are currently
planning
will only slow the growth in emissions
we need to do more than that
to have a hope of limiting global
warming to 1.5 degrees we need to cut
global emissions in half by 2030
and get to net zero by 2050. let's go
through the numbers
of the 36 countries analyzed only two
are taking enough action to restrain
global warming to 1.5 degrees
the gambia has pledged to reduce its
emissions despite being one of the
developing countries that has
contributed least to the problem
and morocco is building more and more
solar power
every other country is failing 2020
is the year national governments were
supposed to come together and strengthen
their targets
so far only a few have done so while
others have announced they're sticking
with their existing
insufficient targets now some countries
aren't too far behind the gambia and
morocco
such as india and kenya but the
countries with the most advanced
economies
those with the greatest capacity to
innovate and help others
are shirking their responsibilities to
lead the united states is currently
withdrawing from the paris agreement
china shows promise its pledge to
balance out its carbon emissions by 2060
could save the world as much as .3
degrees celsius of global warming
but actions on the ground remain divided
china
is the largest market for wind and solar
power but also for new
coal-fired power plants and the eu is
taking steps in the right
direction with its green deal to make
member countries more sustainable but
this deal
is still not enough for 1.5 degrees
so are there any signs of hope one key
measure is a country's willingness to
clean up electricity
clean power can enable other sectors to
reduce or eliminate emissions
more than 50 countries 30 regions 160
cities and 200 businesses have committed
to 100
clean electricity denmark scotland
and the state of south australia are
almost there already but much of the
world still needs to commit to
and accelerate this energy transition
there's more good news in the
transportation sector more than 20
countries
five regions 50 cities and 60 businesses
have already committed to 100
emission-free cars
motorcycles and buses norway is
mandating the end of all sales of fossil
fuel cars by 2025.
meanwhile the us is allowing companies
to make cars that don't travel as far on
a gallon of gas
rolling back fuel efficiency standards
other sectors such as steel and cement
making or aviation and shipping
are even further behind and trickier to
clean up
but some steel and cement companies are
developing carbon-free production
and norway and scotland are targeting
carbon-free short-haul flights
in november 2015 197 countries came
together in paris and set targets to
fight climate change
these targets were already insufficient
to reach the stated goal of limiting
global warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
and most are not on track to achieve
even their own inadequate targets
we need more ambitious targets and much
more ambitious actions
in the next decade we need to transform
key sectors of the global economy
in order to reduce emissions these
changes will be difficult but not
impossible
because they will also bring enormous
opportunities like creating millions of
jobs
and don't lose track of this key point
such a transformation will also mean
cleaner air and a safer more stable
climate
for all
you